and even when you're struggling even
when you're discouraged and you feel
like other people have given up on you
don't ever give up on yourself the
difference between the people who make
it is they just refuse to give up
now of course walked into the Navy SEAL
recruiters office he looked at me and
said only been 35 african-americans and
70 years make it through you know I said
to myself what if I can be the 36th rise
and shine it's an spresso time good
morning believe nation it seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so grab your coffee and sip on
today's message refuse to give up over
to you Barack Obama Jazmin Perez from
Roma Texas Jazmin didn't speak English
when she first started school
neither of her parents had gone to
college but she worked hard earned good
grades and got a scholarship to Brown
University is now in graduate school
studying public health on her way to
becoming doctor Jazmin Perez I'm
thinking about Andoni Schultz from Los
Altos California who's fought brain
cancer since he was three he's had to
endure all sorts of treatments and
surgeries one of which affected his
memory so took him much longer
hundreds of extra hours to do his score
but he never fell behind he's headed to
college this fall and then there's
Chantel Steve from my home town of
Chicago Illinois
even when bouncing from foster home to
foster home in the toughest
neighborhoods in the city she managed to
get a job at a local health care center
start a program to keep young people out
of gangs and she's on track to graduate
high school with honors and go on to
college and jasmine and Dhoni and
Chantel aren't any different from
any of you they face challenges in their
lives just like you do in some cases
they've got it a lot worse off than many
of you but they refuse to give up they
chose to take responsibility for their
lives for their education and set goals
for themselves and even when you're
struggling even when you're discouraged
and you feel like other people have
given up on you don't ever give up on
yourself hearing stories like this
always makes me think about the problems
that I have in my life and realize how
insignificant my problems are if I look
at my ancestors who had to fight in wars
or I look at successful stories of
people who've gone on and done amazing
things I'm sitting here complaining
about the internet being too slow or
having to wait 20 extra seconds for an
elevator to come look whatever problem
you think is so big in your life if you
have just a little bit of perspective
you realize how fortunate you are and
how that problem is not really all that
big you've just convinced yourself that
it is one of my favorite stories along
these lines is Oprah Winfrey this woman
grew up in just terrible conditions she
wasn't raised by her parents she got
sexually abused her upbringing was so
poor that she had to go to school in
potato sacks her grandmother would buy
bags of potatoes and cut the bags up and
then sew them into a dress and that's
what she would go to school in because
they couldn't afford to actually buy her
real clothes can you imagine how hard
that is like you're growing up without
parents you're growing up being sexually
abused you're growing up so poor that
you're wearing potato sacks and how she
must have been ridiculed going to school
and you think that your life is hard you
think that your situation is so
challenging and I always use that as a
source inspiration because if Oprah can
go from that place that she was at to
where she is at now what's your Excuse
what's my excuse and really when you ask
yourself that question whatever reason
comes back is really just an excuse the
difference between the people who make
it is they just refuse to give up they
don't quit when you quit they keep going
they continue to find a way and so
adopting that mindset adopting that
mentality of never feeling
for yourself that there's always a
solution end up by continuing on you'll
eventually find your path you'll
eventually hit the mark that you're
trying to accomplish look at the people
that you look up to whoever they are the
people at the top of their game in any
industry chances are they started off
with less than what you already have
right now go back to their origin story
chances are it wasn't just handed to
them it wasn't easy
they had less than what you already have
right now the difference is they didn't
give up on themselves they refused to
quit and that's why they want now I have
a very special bonus clip for you but
before that my question the day is who
is the person you look up to the most
who refused to quit who was that person
and why leave it on the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
enjoy the bonus clip and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
event espresso
[Music]
I would like to know when you're in that
moment failing and you have to keep
going what do you say to yourself what
if a lot of times I'll be in a tours at
Mile Run or something like that
and I'm all jacked up body's broken
mines broken spirits broken I started to
say what if I can pull this off when I
first walked into the Navy SEAL
recruiters office he looked at me and
said only been 35 african-americans and
70 years make it through you know I said
to myself what if I can be the 36 it's
the what if I can pull off miracle
what if I can become someone that no one
thinks I can be and just that just me
talking about that
I haven't hair growing up on my arms
because it makes me just like what if I
can be that guy that people who called
[ __ ] and this and that and now I'm
speaking at Toms favorite event what is
yes studies of directing at Howard so
even though I was you know thinking of
theater and thinking of film I was
thinking about you know being behind the
camera being you know in the in the
audience
blocking scenes as opposed to being on
stage and is there a point work got more
serious as an actor and kind of give up
the direction your day job I haven't I
haven't I haven't given it up I still
haven't given it up no I think I think
directing is in my future you know I've
recently sold a pitch to Universal some
writing something you know so it's not
it's not like I've given that up it's
just that you know kind of want to write
right now and I shouldn't get off of it
you know I grew up I wasn't the richest
but I had a rich family in spirit and in
support and you know standing here with
nineteen championships is something I
never thought would happen you know just
I went on the courts with just a ball
and a racket and a hope and and that's
all I had and I it's inspiring for all
you guys out there that want to do
something and want to be the best that
you can be and want to do the best that
you can do you just never give up
because you never know what can happen
you never know who you can inspire and
who you can influence the most important
word ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple so it would be like
a little beacon hey believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details